oh oh my goodness whoa whoa what what's
the problem it's been 15 years since
Enchanted and the sequel promised to be
more musical than ever which of these
returning stars is getting their chance
to shine and which one froze up at the
very idea of singing let's get into it
we have a fairy tale life number one
this must have been a shock Gabriella
baldekino thought she was joining a zoom
meeting for another round of auditions
when Amy Adams suddenly joined the chat
and announced that bald Aquino had
gotten the role of giselle's
step-daughter Morgan I'm sure
congratulations
original actress Rachel Convoy who's
just a little too old for the role now
nonetheless showed her support on the
blue carpet for disenchanted at the El
Capitan theater in Hollywood number two
say it with a song songwriters Alan
Menken and Steven Schwartz wrote seven
new songs for disenchanted including
reprisals Menken has admitted that they
took inspiration from old Disney
Classics such as Snow White and
Cinderella on top of that Schwartz also
challenged Megan to write what they
described as an homage to Defying
Gravity from Wicked disenchanted is
meant to be more musical than its
predecessor and every single character
will be singing this time I love this
score I do I love the score deeply
number three who would have thought
McDreamy gets stage fright Patrick
Dempsey was terrified to sing and
disenchanted considering he's never sang
before in public and he was starring
alongside such musical talents as Amy
Adams and Idina Menzel when asked if she
gave Dempsey any tips on set Menzel
replied I don't give advice like that
and he should just be himself and enjoy
the moment it was nice to be in your
world oh yeah you did an amazing he
respond I had a great time and it was an
honor to be a part of it number four
what an enchanting setting much of
disenchanted was shot in Ireland with
the fictional Monroeville actually being
repurposed out of the small Irish
village of enes scary Wicklow this Tiny
Town nestled in the foothills of a
beautiful mountainous region is
sometimes referred to as the garden of
Ireland the whole environment had this
magical quality to it what setting could
be better suited for making our cast
truly feel as though they're living a
fairy tale working in Ireland it's just
been a dream number five Amy Adams
definitely felt her age with this
choreography I'm required to dance in
this in an interview with Jimmy Fallon
Adams discussed how the last time she
danced she was still in her 20 now that
she's returning to the role of Gisele in
her 40s Adams has said in my heart I
look like I'm in my 20s when I'm dancing
and yet when she went to watch her
dancing back in playback she was shocked
wow that's
not the same number six Amy Adams made
disenchanted for her daughter the
critically acclaimed actress has made a
number of movies that her daughter can't
watch leading to her daughter asking if
she can make another movie like
Enchanted Adams has also said that
becoming a mother has made her want to
teach her daughter that moving forward
can be just as enchanting is looking
back if you look closely you can even
see Adam's daughter make a brief cameo
in the Marketplace close to the
beginning of the movie she just had a
lot of questions about how I was
behaving yeah that was her thing number
seven these two actresses have been
friends for years at a birthday party
birthday party yes that's right the pair
of them first met at a party when Maya
Rudolph correctly predicted that Amy
Adams was pregnant and even despite
their years of familiarity Rudolph was
stunned when she saw Amy Adams in
costume she felt like she was actually
talking to Giselle stating I knew that
Amy was doing it for me but I felt like
a kid like when little girls are talking
to a princess at Disneyland it's so
lovely to talk to Giselle Giselle is
real number eight what would an
andalasian princess from New York sound
like Idina Menzel spent plenty of time
considering this on the set of
disenchanted admitting that she agonized
over her accent with director Adam
shankman her character Nancy has been
through some pretty big changes since
the first film coming from being a
cynical New York chick to spending 15
years in the fairy tale world of
andalasia and Idina Menzel needed to
find the balance so I try to just be
cool and number nine Amy Adams has a lot
of experience talking to herself before
taking off to Ireland a few of the more
CG animated scenes were filmed in studio
especially the scenes that have Giselle
speaking with Pip so when it came time
for Amy Adams to talk to herself as
giselle's evil stepmother Persona she
apparently found it easy to do because
as she put it I've been talking to
myself for a couple of weeks I'm one of
those people who thinks that it's really
funny number 10 sometimes you gotta do
what you gotta do filming for
disenchanted started during quarantine
and so Amy Adams recorded the first few
tracks of the songs in her coat closet
from home some of the audio recorded
from her closet even made it into the
movie the lyrics to fairy tale life hit
her especially hard during this time as
she found it to be a reminder to just
appreciate and love those around you
number 11. Enchanted had some pretty
impressive costumes one of the most
magical things about being back in the
world of Enchanted is wearing fabulous
costume with the wedding dress that Amy
Adams wore in the first movie apparently
weighing a grueling 45 pounds there were
some high expectations for the outfits
for the sequel the costume designer for
disenchanted is Joan Bergen who went for
a more romantic storybook feel this time
around Idina Menzel has commented on how
the costumes helped her to better get
into character stay dating from you it's
great because I get to dress up and wear
a corset and feel really honored number
12 did you recognize these references
several of the costumes in disenchanted
are meant to serve as callbacks to
previous Disney films the three garden
fairies are dressed in blue red and
green as a reference to flora fauna and
Merryweather from Sleeping Beauty
Morgan's blue dress is meant to resemble
Cinderellas and in the final scene
Gisele is styled after lady Tremaine
Tyson resembles Prince Charming and
Rosaline and Ruby are dressed similarly
to Cinderella's Wicked stepsisters
number 13. filming a musical is hard
work when discussing what she had to do
to prepare for her dueling villain song
with Amy Adams Maya Rudolph said I felt
like I was training for a marathon and
with good reason it took them 10
straight hours to film the scene and yet
despite the long hours and grueling
training process Rudolph felt as though
she were living a dream stating it felt
so good and so gratifying because it was
the culmination of all of the hard work
number 14 talk about short notice the
ticks Griffin Newman was approached by
producer Barry Josephson about
auditioning for disenchanted but he
didn't think that he was being
considered for the role of pip until the
last minute still he impressed Amy Adams
so much that she called up Josephson
afterward to tell him I think we should
hire that guy so you bet on wish that
wish quick number 15 you can see real
magic whenever these two are together
Steven Schwartz who Idina Menzel has
described as my fairy Godmother when it
comes to musicals has promised to give
the songstress her own musical Solo in
disenchanted this is to make up for the
fact that Enchanted was supposed to end
with a massive musical number by Menzel
that was ultimately cut from the final
film number 16. time to go back to the
drawing board rishu boots for
disenchanted were performed in England
and New York City after an initial
screening of the film received mixed
reviews this led to some concern among
fans regarding how much of the movie was
going to be Rewritten and if any of what
was filmed in Ireland was ever going to
make it to the screen at all prompting
director Adam shankman to promise all of
Ireland is still there we just shot a
couple scenes that had been cut
Enchanted was clearly a magical
experience for our cast and we are glad
to hear that they've had just as much
fun on the set for disenchanted which of
these returning stars are you excited to
see take on their iconic roles yet again
make sure to let us know down in the
comments